portland
oakland y nueva york- la absolución de
kyle reading house desató protestas por
todo eeuu
es simplemente absurdo y revelar lo roto
que está el sistema es rittenhouse mató
a dos hombres e hirió a un tercero
durante las protestas contra el racismo
en que no sea en agosto de 2020 el joven
de 18 años que utilizó una arma
semiautomática un ar-15 declaró actuar
en defensa propia se enfrentaba a la
posibilidad de la cadena perpetua al
conocerse el veredicto dos familiares de
las víctimas se mostraron desolados
todos los días me gustaría poder volver
a casa con él y quitarme algo de peso de
encima pero no puedo porque está muerto
y ahora el sistema me dice que nadie es
responsable de eso y eso es un problema
siento que en este caso es como si las
vidas de las víctimas no importaran y no
creo que eso sea aceptable y eso es lo
que está en mi corazón de verdad
rittenhouse se ha convertido en un icono
en algunos círculos de la derecha en el
último año su caso cristaliza la tensión
política en eeuu sobre el tema del
control de armas en el momento de los
hechos-- donald trump era el presidente
éste ya había apoyado al joven y ahora
le felicito por su absolución diferente
reacción tuvo su sucesor joe biden en un
primer momento mostró solidaridad con el
jurado para después emitir un comunicado
de condena aunque el veredicto de que no
sea provocará que muchos estadounidenses
se sientan enojados y preocupados
incluido yo mismo debemos reconocer que
el jurado ha hablado
el mandatario llamó a la población a
mantener la calma sin embargo la ira
podría volver a despertar el movimiento
la clase mater las vidas negras importan
que en 2020 protagonizó las que fueron
las protestas anti racistas más grandes
en décadas
[Aplausos]